Once upon a time, there lived a man named Geppetto.
He was old and lonely.
One day, Geppetto was making a puppet.
I'll call you Pinocchio.
I wish you were a real boy.
Then the Blue Fairy appeared.
Geppetto, you are a good man.
I'll grant you your wish.
She touched Pinocchio with her wand.
"Wake up, Pinocchio.",...
...the Fairy said.
If you are brave, truthful and unselfish, you will be a real boy.
The next day, Pinocchio wanted to go to school.
Here is your book.
Go to school quickly.
Thank you, dad. Good-bye.
On the way to school, Pinocchio saw a show.
What's that?
A great puppet show!
Pinocchio forgot about school.
Lock Pinocchio in a cage.
I need him to get a lot of money!
The show was finished.
Let me go! Let me go, please!